Now take a look at this set of digits and
count how many times the digit nine appears.
How long did it take you to recognize the number of nines this time?
Much faster, right?
It's pretty incredible that such a small change, such as color,
can allow us to recognize and instantly process this digit nine more quickly.
I want you to take a guess at how fast pre-attentive processing just
happened for you.
Now, you may not know which of these is the correct answer, which is fine.
I encourage you to try each of them out and
see how the real world compares to these short timespans.
You'll see what I mean when the site gives you feedback.